[Musique]
l'air qui nous entoure n'est pas faite
vite les replay pleine particules fines
des poussières du pollen dépôt mortes
mais il y a aussi des micro-organismes
des virus ou des bactéries qui peuvent
se déplacer dans l'herbe où se fixer sur
ces particules fines c'est ce qu'on
appelle des bio aérosols mettant la
question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui c'est
est-ce que des bactéries vivant tout
morte qui serait porteuse de gènes de
résistance aux antibiotiques pourraient
se déplacer sur de longues distances et
venir contaminer nos milieux de vie
c'est à Québec au centre de recherche de
l'Institut universitaire de cardiologie
et de pneumologie que s'amorce ce grand
projet de recherche
une étude de lait aussi bien dans les
milieux de soins que les milieux
agricoles dans les campagnes comme dans
les villes au niveau du sol et dans
l'atmosphère
Caroline Duchêne experte en matière
d'aérosol pilote le projet qui fait
appel à différents groupes de chercheurs
et d'expertise ici et à l'étranger
son rôle qu'il joue globalement dans
notre propre acquisition de bactéries
multirisantes et complètement inconnue
dans la littérature actuellement mais
aussi on ne sait pas encore comment
intégrer les valeurs de l'air dans les
calculs de risque individuels ou de
population
[Musique]
c'est notre usage excessif fait souvent
inapproprié d'antibiotiques qu'à
favoriser le développement de bactéries
plus résistantes
aujourd'hui plusieurs pays dans le monde
sont confrontés aux risques que de
simples infections deviennent mortels
faute d'efficacité des antibiotiques en
fait 2019 une année charnière pour la
première fois on a documenté qui avait
plus de morts causer directement par la
résistance aux antibiotiques que demeure
causées par la malaria ou par le VIH
sida dans le monde
les antibiotiques qu'on le sait c'est
aussi répandu dans certains élevages et
avec lui la probabilité qu'il se
développe des bactéries résistantes aux
antibiotiques des bactéries qui peuvent
se retrouver dans le fumier
Jérémie
de garde stéphane goodbou est ingénieur
en agro-environnement il participe au
projet de recherche
souvent un peu comme l'humain il y a des
rejets qui peuvent suivre le traitement
médical par exemple c'est des présences
par exemple d'antibiotiques ou quelque
chose ou de bactéries résistantes il
faut aller dans le lisier c'est ça
l'intérêt l'installation de Stéphane est
unique en son genre un endroit clos dans
lequel il réalise de mini épandages de
fumiers ou de lisier avec en prime la
possibilité de mesurer ce qui s'échappe
de l'air en bien durant les pandas
est-ce que ça va être aller dans l'air
ou ça va rester au sol c'est ça qui nous
intéresse
l'échantillonnage se fait à l'aide de
filtre qui vont capter à la sortie de la
serre les aérosols émis lors de
l'épandage on mesure l'air à l'entrée et
à la sortie on connaît toutes les débit
d'airs qui passent et puis on regarde
alors l'épandage est-ce qu'il est
concentration dans leur changent dû à
l'épandage de différents composés là ça
peut être des poussières et des gaz ou
encore les bio aérosols
des échantillons d'air sont aussi
prélevés dans des fermes d'élevage et
dans des usines d'épurations les
déjections humaines sont une autre
source potentielle de bactéries
résistante aux antibiotiques
[Musique]
si on considère qu'un bâtiment est
considéré comme une cheminée comme une
source ponctuelle dans l'environnement
comment est-ce que ce qui est mis à
partir de cette source là peut voyager
en termes de distance autant en hauteur
quand distance horizontale comment
est-ce que c'est source-là vont
éventuellement impacter chaque nous on
est exposé
mais au-delà des sources individuelles
d'émissions on peut se demander comment
tracer un portrait plus global à
l'échelle d'un pays par exemple des
bactéries auxquelles on est exposé et de
leur résistance potentielle des
antibiotiques mais on peut le faire avec
ceci parce que chaque voiture dispose
d'un filtre à air une filtre à l'air
avant qu'il entre dans l'habitacle il va
donc capturer des poussières ou des
bactéries et Paul George en a récupéré
dans 51 villes au Canada
au lieu d'un post fixe qui ne capture
que l'air qu'il atteint on opte plutôt
pour une méthode mobile cela procure un
plus large échantillonnage de l'air et
ce dans les différents environnements
rencontrés au quotidien
des filtres du genre Paul en analyse
près de 500 à partir d'une pièce
découpée dans chacun il pourra extraire
les micro-organismes qui s'y trouvent
les statuts déloge la poussière contenue
dans le filtre elle est relâchée dans le
liquide ensuite dans une centrifugeuse
ces éléments sont concentrés avant de
procéder à une extraction de l'ADN
ensuite à l'aide d'une analyse PCR plus
poussée il serait capable de qualifier
et de quantifier la présence de gènes de
résistance aux antibiotiques qu'il
observent au Canada les villes de
Montréal vont couvert et Toronto ont
montré les taux les plus élevés pour le
reste c'était des niveaux de base plutôt
similaires ce qui me fait dire que plus
il y a de gens et de véhicules plus il y
a poussière plus il y a de bactéries
dans l'air
[Musique]
si les bactéries résistantes aux
antibiotiques peuvent se disperser sur
de grandes distances au sol elles
peuvent aussi potentiellement se
disperser dans les nuages
à une certaine altitude les vents plus
forts vont vite transporter les
bactéries d'une région à l'autre
vraiment les bactéries peuvent se
déplacer sur des dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres donc ça peut être des gènes
de résistance qui sont soit portés par
la bactérie qui transitent dans
l'atmosphère mais ça peut être aussi de
l'ADN libre et qui vont eux aussi être
capables de transiter sur des très
longues distances
Florent aussi a pu le mesurer sur des
échantillons récupérés ici au sommet du
Puy-de-Dôme en France
un site de recherche exceptionnel sur la
route des nuages nous les nuages qu'on
va capturer au Puy-de-Dôme ça va être
des nuages qui vont transiter donc à peu
près l'altitude du Puy-de-Dôme donc 1400
mètres d'altitude
à l'aide de cet appareil on aspire un
échantillon du nuage qu'on emmagasine
dans un liquide
les analyses ultérieures montrent que
les nuages contiennent des gènes de
résistance aux antibiotiques on a
observé jusqu'à présent environ 29 gènes
de résistance différents
et à des concentrations qui sont pas
négligeables puisqu'on estime que on
aurait à peu près en 7 gènes de
résistance par cellule bactérienne dans
les nuages
ces bactéries qui voyagent dans l'air et
qui se dépose ensuite un peu partout ont
également la capacité d'échanger des
gènes de résistance avec les autres
bactéries qui se trouvent à proximité
et les bactéries ont acquis au fil du
temps une grande capacité à transmettre
leurs gènes de façon hyper efficace
elles peuvent transmettre comme nous
leur bagages génétique à leur
descendants de façon verticale mais
aussi à leurs voisines nos parents de
manière horizontale
et par la suite les bactéries qui vont
l'avoir à qui cette capacité aux
antibiotiques de manière horizontale
elles vont pouvoir le transmettre à leur
descendance à leur tour de manière
verticale
plus étonnant encore une bactérie
vivante peut acquérir des gènes de
résistance aux antibiotiques d'une
bactérie morte
donc dans l'environnement on s'intéresse
de plus en plus à l'ADN résiduel de ces
bactéries mortels qui elles peuvent être
des sources de disons de jeunes de
résistance pour d'autres bactéries
complètement inoffensives qui se
trouvent autour d'elle
ces bactéries inoffensives pour du main
pourrait donc acquérir des gènes de
résistance aux antibiotiques
éventuellement les transférer à des
bactéries pathogènes qui croisent leur
route
mais comment savoir si ces bactéries ont
survécu à leur transit dans l'air le
fait d'en capturer dans les filtres ne
veut pas dire qu'elles sont viables
leur passage dans l'air qu'on appelle
l'aérosolisation soumet les bactéries à
tout un lot de stress écarte de
température et d'humidité présence
d’oxygène exposition au rayon du soleil
certaines n'y survivront pas mais
d'autres tiendront le coup elles vont
conserver le cas échéant leur capacité à
résister à des antibiotiques
comment sait-on en plaçant ses bactéries
capturées dans l'air dans un milieu de
culture
en 48 heures les bactéries qui ont
résisté au passage dans l'air se
multiplient à nouveau
au centre du pétri de culture une
languette contient des antibiotiques
la languette on peut se poser qu'un
ventes résistante à antibiotique qui va
être présent sur la langue
une preuve que certaines de ces
bactéries s'acclimata tout même au
stress qu’elle subissent dans l'air en
fait il faut déjà prendre pour acquis
qu'une bactérie qui a réussi à passer à
travers toutes ces étapes qui se
retrouvent dans des bio aérosols qui
acquis des gens de résistance aux
antibiotiques c'est déjà un seul Viber
mais c'est survivante ont-elles le
potentiel de se multiplier en nous quand
on les inale ou les avale est-ce
qu'elles peuvent coloniser l'intestin
par exemple les voies respiratoires
donc s'installer bien sûr survivre et
peut-être même transférer leurs jeunes à
d'autres types de bactéries et c'est
notre rôle dans mon laboratoire de les
vérifier cette hypothèse
l'expérience sera menée à l'aide des
souris la méthode employée serait
similaire à celle utilisée dans le passé
pour d'autres types de tests soit
l'ingurgitation d'une solution quand on
a ce qu'elle ci des bactéries
résistantes aux antibiotiques récoltées
dans l'air d'autres souris y seront
exposés par les voies nasales
dans l'intestin qui vont en fait
prévenir la croissance de ce nouveau
venu dans l'écosystème est-ce que
l'expression des gens de résistance aux
antibiotiques va être la même est-ce que
votre augmenter ce qu'elle va être
diminuée ça on va pouvoir le l'analyser
le démontrer dans ses études
les résultats à venir devraient
permettre de mesurer à quel risque qu'on
s'expose en général dans notre
environnement ou selon notre proximité
des sources potentielles des missions de
sé bactéries on n'est pas obligé de
trouver un problème on veut juste voir
comment ça contribue si ça contribue et
à quelle mesure mesurer le risque c'est
quelque chose de très très très
difficile parce que contrairement des
agents chimiques par exemple pour
lesquels on a des recommandations on
connaît très bien la toxicité ou la
toxicologie ou la cinétique d'un produit
on n'est pas capable de dire encore et
ce pour aucun bio aérosol quand vous
êtes exposé à plus que de temps vous
avez tel risque de développer tel
problème
le problème avec les micro-organismes
résistants aux antibiotiques c'est que
l'air pourrait les faire voyager
beaucoup plus vite et plus loin qu'on ne
le pense
[Musique]